c'est glacé sa tranche le vent mais la
hâte et sans dans les boyaux comme la
rosée du matin sous les eaux
bong l'autre cas
ma
il
bonsoir c'est toute la magie du cinéma
cette image d'un jean carmet souvent
drôle parfois tendres ou bien râleurs
restera à jamais à jamais jean carmet
mort hier dans sa maison de seine près
de paris mort naturelle il avait 73 ans
il était aimé des français il était l'un
des acteurs les plus populaires mais il
avait su rester simple sobre humain
simplement humain et il est parti comme
il vivait sans crier gare pascal des
changes jacques dufour faveur joyeux
drilles des compagnons quelqu'un nous
espérons voir l'autre encore continuer à
les nouveaux avantages de rôle en rôle
mais là les messieurs sans carnet quart
mais avec un c comme césar mais surtout
avec un c comme copains d'abord et
toujours la grande guerre
et compagnie c'est l oms le litani leurs
prêts dans leur amphithéâtre
le terrain on a l'habitude de le
partager à plusieurs est bien celui là
je ne le partage pas je garde pour moi
tout seul ce césar c'est peut-être la
seule chose qu'il n'ait pas partagé avec
ses potes c'est que ça c'est un ami il
est blessé la cuisse il a perdu beaucoup
de sang je suis formé saint georges
vous pouvez extraire une balle et faire
un pansement sur une base ils avaient la
balle en jeu a comme amoureux des bonnes
choses de certaines îles partager la
passion avec beaucoup d'autres le vin
par exemple et encore pas n'importe
lequel le vin de loire le 26 lui il ya
des départs fans mur de framboise de 2,2
pronos alors il ya d'autres plus
originales qu'il partageait avec un
cercle beaucoup plus restreint le fait
que c'est une chose qui se perd dans le
godet gens les pages qui était
quelquefois ils ont perdu le goût de ce
qu'est de vrai fromage de tête alors on
l'est on voit les ramener un
gouvernement rigoureux un commodat souci
il fit sa première fugue ya quatre ans
et non perdit jamais le goût
messieurs s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît vous ouvrez votre bijou est rien
et ça c'est rien ça c'est rien car mais
c'était aussi le r de rôle en 46 ans de
carrière il en a joué beaucoup des
grands et des petits
toujours avec générosité sans stratégie
sans calcul carriériste 6e couteau
figure en premier rôle à chaque fois du
losc au tragique
il était parfait juste émouvant magal on
prend pas mal à prouver à réformer et
travaille pour les molécules m'en fous
pas mal pourquoi les vaches sont les
idées car mais enfin tu es comme
télévision s'ils commencent à la radio
dans la famille duraton c'est là qu'il
fit ses dernières apparitions et c'est
là qu'est glana d'autres récompenses et
finalement ils les huttes ou même
l'oscar de la charcuterie on aurait pu
dire encore beaucoup d'autres choses
d comme têtue touche à tout le temps
jean carmet c'était tout cela à la fois
pour m'embrasser au rendez vous des bons
copains y avait pas souvent de lapin
quand l'un d'entre eux manquait d'abord
c'est qu'il était mort
oui mais jamais au grand jamais son taux
dans lone se refermait s'entend après
coquin de sort
il manquait tongs comme jean carmet ray
le sens de l'amitié entretenait des
relations fortes avec ses copains de
fête et de tournage relation dénué
d'hypocrisie ou de mondanités ses
copains ont pleuré ce matin nicolas
winckler pascal de ces bons georges en
selle un camion gris pour emmener le
corps de jean carmet à la morgue de
l'hôpital de sèvres la couleur ne lui
aurait certainement pas pris tôt ce
matin c'est gérard depardieu qui est
venu le premier rendre hommage à son
meilleur ami il partageait avec lui sa
passion pour le vin de loire
il avait même choisi d'en produire
ensemble d'amis jean carmet n'en manquez
pas le pierre tchernia etienne chatillez
en passant par guy béart ou bernard
fresson il pleure aujourd'hui l'acteur
mais aussi l'ami sans faille
c'est un titre que je trouve absolument
magnifique ça fait trente ans que je le
connais et ils avaient une une fidélité
amical que je ne connais pas beaucoup
leur métier c'était un bibliophile
fanatiques c'était un très fin
connaisseur de
quand de musique et c'est qu'elle fasse
seulement l'amateur de bonnes bouteilles
de bonne bouffe et de rigolade qu'on
connaissait publiquement chacun pouvait
un moment donné se reconnaître en lui
c'est ça qu'ils avaient de formidables
ils étaient vous il est témoin il était
non c'est connu dans les années 40 moins
de 20 ans dès juillet lui va pas moi dix
mots tendres rester amis pendant 50 ans
des tas de souvenirs merveilleux
ensemble
le corps de jean carmet restera au
funérarium de sèvres jusqu'à la messe
funèbre célébré lundi en l'église saint
roch à paris
quand il ne tournait pas jean carmet
retourner dans ses terres en touraine à
bourgueil dans ce village de 5000
habitants où il goûté aux charmes de la
vie car mais va manquer à bourgueil
valérie gage et clemenceau jeunes gens
rient côtier jean carmet n'avait pas
trois ans quand ils se sont connus
ensemble ils ont fait les 400 coups vous
interdisez surtout de descendre à la
cave à bourgueil la demeure familiale de
jean carmet accueille aujourd'hui la
maison du vin c'était une grande fierté
pour cet amoureux de la touraine qu'ici
comme ailleurs n'a jamais joué les stars
des principaux traits de son caractère
c'est sa fidélité en amitié lie c'est
vrai et toujours il parlait de de ses
amis d'enfance de son école de sa genèse
des amis de sa famille
et pour lui c'était 7 et ce qui compte
et jean carmet a quitté bourgueil à
l'âge de 11 ans pour aller au lycée a
tous moi mais dès qu'il avait un moment
il revenait au pays entraînant ses amis
dans une tournée des bonnes tables est
venu avec l' empire coffre il est venu
avec depardieu et quand ils venaient à
la maison il sonnait très volontiers
sachant que la maison lui serait
toujours ouverte
j'ai connu est un petit quand il faisait
il met en vacances qui faisait du vélo
sur la place de l'église qu'elle vous
fait l'annoncé de son décès fait sa
rentrée
savita me touche parce que c'était
quelqu'un connu quelqu'un un comique
intelligent juste à côté de l'école où
jean carmet en font usage ses fonds de
culotte et un cinéma aujourd'hui sur la
fiche d'un de ses films on pouvait y
lire de ligne toute simple le discret
hommage de bourgueil à l'un des siens
jean carmet aura tourné avec les plus
grands metteurs en scène yves robert que
nous allons retrouver dans un instant
direct yves boisset claude chabrol
jacques rouffio bertrand blier francis
girod robert hossein ou claude berri il
aura aussi donner la réplique à tous les
grands acteurs des années 80 et 90 il
mérite donc un hommage de la grande
famille du cinéma
il était effectivement comme ils dansent
et fine le bonhomme quoi le lam il c'est
pour ça que je croyais représentait
tellement dans le paysage comme on dit
on les acteurs français qu on al
impression qu est l appui toujours et
qu'il y resterait c'est perdre un peu un
oncle hammami a moyen de pallier
quelqu'un qui existe moi j'ai des
souvenirs de jean depuis toujours
je vois j'étais moi la plaie de répondre
des trains choses comme ça devrait me
prendre des trains en se disant tiens je
le regarde je me vois un billet pour la
il partait comme ça c'est le genre de
choses et muet bien ferme oui il y avait
un jardin secret à mon avis yves cas
très important j'ai joué mais qu'est ce
qui vous arrive
ce que je pourrais pas venir chez vous
chez moi pourquoi c'est l'effroi
n'attendez pas au confort c'est vrai que
par exemple dans merci la vie que j'ai
tourné avec lui après la mort de mon
père j'ai eu très nettement le sentiment
que c'était un peu comme comme si mon
père avait été encore un petit peu là
enfin par jean carmet interposés y avait
ça c'était forcément ils ont ils sont
morts même âge tous les deux c'est
curieux j'étais très proche et donc
pensent que parce qu'on a les mêmes que
gérard depardieu avait les mêmes
rapports avec carmet que moi c'est
pareil c'est une espèce de pair deuxième
de ma confiance
vous payez pour vous faire confiance
rappelle moi tu jubilait il est même à
jouer mais ça donc il aimait bien faire
son métier il était et est attentif à
chaque détail est donc ils se mettaient
en condition il y avait des tic qui sont
restés célèbres par exemple avant de
chaque plan il dissout fait votre sens
élevé comme ça pour ce pour chasser les
vilaines pensées voir derrière moi je ne
compare à bourvil un peu parce que c'est
des gens qui sont des gens populaires
mais en même temps qui cherche à
s'élever dans la vie mais sans le dit
pas assez c'est un type qui connaissait
bien de signer il connaissait le cinéma
américain connaissait le cinéma français
il s'intéressait à ses rôles à tout même
à ce qu'il ne concernait pas directement
regardez les gens vivre et ça c'est
formidable parce que les acteurs sont
pas tous comme ça
donnez-moi yves robert vous êtes en
direct sur votre plateau tournage merci
d'interrompre votre classe pour nous
dire un mot
bertrand parvaud delpech raconte
aujourd'hui dans le monde une de vos
confidences tournage de l'été 36 jean
carmet nous faisait rire à l'écran il
vous faisait rire aussi sur le plateau
de tournage
oh oui jean ah bon la plaine jeanjean
gens c'était tout à fait autre chose
qu'un camarade qu'un copain qu'un ami
c'était quelqu'un de la famille qu'est
ce qu'un de la bande
je penche pour un brassens comme ça
qu'il devait car l'un d'entre eux
manquait d'abord chez qui il était mort
oui mais jamais au grand jamais son trou
dans l'eau ne se refermait et le
changement le trou de chercheurs - port
on met même envie de te dire à bientôt
tellement aimé fort mais j'en étais un
déconneur formidable magnifique par
exemple il m'a appris une chose je
disais j'ai jamais dit actionne je
disais partait et une fois on était bien
en place comme ça je dis partez sa
voiture n'était pas loin il est monté
dans sa voiture et les parkings
il est rentré chez lui quoi alors après
j'ai dit jouer c'est aussi beaucoup
partent et sinon bien je lui dois
beaucoup de choses à à cet homme lui
doit par exemple une espèce de
d'extraordinaire recueillement avant de
jouer de retour à l'enfance comme ça il
avait conservé je crois d comme les
vrais artistes je pense un prolongement
de l'enfance
il avait une innocence magnifique un
étonnement formidable alors quoi
demander de mieux un acteur que des très
tonique ce qui fait et cette innocence
et yves robert il ne la jouait pas il
l'était réellement dans la vie
j'étais plus malin que ça comme vous le
connaissiez très bien on n'a même pas
envie de vous poser des questions non on
a envie de vous écouter comme ça parlait
de juin
je connaissais bien parce que je
connaissais que autrement que comme
acteur je connaissais que dans la ville
venaient à noël passé au premier de l'an
passé le réveillon à la maison fait
partie de la famille
c'est lé rapport était perpétuellement
ironique
un jour je le vois dans un film du
déguisant dame mona et je téléphone il
tombe sur un répondeur et je lui fais un
chapelet de félicitations et le
lendemain je reçois une lettre
recommandée en me disant vous voulez
vous s'il vous plaît le livre robert à
l'en-tête de votre production me
me ré écrire sur le papier m'envoyer par
lettre recommandée avec accusé de
réception
toutes les félicitations de la ffct les
rapports de juan sas les permanences on
a parfois l'impression il robert que les
acteurs ou les actrices grisés par leur
notoriété leur succès deviennent
inaccessibles qu'ils éprouvent un
sentiment que ces deux distances
vis-à-vis des autres lui reste est
réellement proche simple accessible aux
autres et à ses amis
je pense que j'en savais qu'il était élu
parce qu'ils écoutaient c'est un élu du
peuple si je puis dire tant pis pour
ceux qui se distancie ou qui prennent de
la distance distancié sont pas du
semencier 180 chiens ils prennent de la
distance avait regarde s'ils veulent
être tout seul mais j'en avais un vrai
besoin d'être en contact avec les gens
qui croisait dans la rue c'était un des
vrais rapports qu'il avait avec les
autres pour rire les gens dans la rue
lui souriez et souvent le tutoyer sets
1-6
il l'aimé parce qu'ils se
reconnaissaient en lui je ne sais pas je
crois qu'il était à la fois différent
comme eux mêmes mais il est un miroir
qui fait des plus belles grimaces ou lui
ou dont les reflets et est plus étonnant
merci yves robert pour ce témoignage or
ces mots que vous avez dit sur sur jean
carmet pour jeanjean il faut faire plein
de fruits merci et et bonsoir merci
mais jean carmet avait 73 ans je vous
précise que ce soir michel field
consacrera une émission spéciale à 00h30
à jean carmet françois mitterrand ainsi
sur l'urgence d'une conférence au sommet
sur la bosnie dans un communiqué publié
cet après midi le chef de l'état
rappelle avoir écrit sur ce point bill
clinton à boris eltsine et au secrétaire
général de l'onu et se réjouit de leur
accord
les grandes puissances tiennent ainsi à
montrer qu'elles entendent réagir à
l'attitude des serbes qui font preuve
d'un véritable acharnement agora ch d
non content de bombarder l'hôpital
ils attaquent maintenant les annexes de
l'établissement isabelle weschler
les serbes de bosnie ne dessert pas
l'étau autour de gorazde plus de 100
personnes auraient péri aujourd'hui dans
la vallée de la drina la population se
taire ou tentent de porter secours à ces
blessés selon le gouvernement bosniaque
les serbes auraient même intimé l'ordre
aux 65 mille prisonniers de l'anah
d'évacuer les deux rives pour se
concentrer sur une zone du centre-ville
de trois kilomètres de long seulement un
ultimatum surréaliste alors que
l'artillerie continue de tuer
les combats se poursuivent avec une
intensité très important les tirs d'obus
s'acharne sur la rive droite et un
centre de secours médical installé à
l'extérieur de l'hôpital sur l'hôpital
était endommagée a été touché par deux
tanks
une dizaine de personnes y seraient
mortes selon d'autres sources médicales
28 personnes auraient péri près de
l'hôpital seul pâté de maisons encore
tenus par les bosniaques sur la rive
droite
cette zone fait donc l'objet d'un
acharnement particulier de la part des
serbes
depuis le début de l'offensive 436
habitants de gorazde auraient été tuées
dans 79 enfants
voilà qui rend encore plus urgente
l'arrivée du convoi d'interposition des
nations unies qui a enfin quitté
sarajevo ce matin c'est 100 soldats et
40 soignants mettront sans doute 24
heures à atteindre l'an clave de gord
ash des 70 km seulement à washington
bill clinton a proposé d'étendre aux
cinq autres enclaves musulmanes dont
corps hd le dispositif de frappes
aériennes qui protège déjà sarajevo mais
paris exprime des réserves
la frappe aérienne n'a de sens que si
elle est dans un projet politique à
sarajevo savez un sens mais l'idée
d'aller frapper tous azimuts partout sur
le territoire de la bosnie pour demander
quoi pour faire quoi après ne me paraît
pas une idée opérationnelle
les grandes puissances prépare une
nouvelle conférence internationale à 4
usa russie europe aux nuls pour remettre
la paix en bosnie sur les rails
pendant l'agonie la diplomatie continue
l'espoir renaît en revanche au
proche-orient shimon peres et yasser
arafat se sont rencontrés à bucarest en
roumanie ils se sont montrés très
optimiste sur la conclusion d'un accord
prochain
mais pourrait être signé au début du
mois de mai et permettra aux
palestiniens d'obtenir leur autonomie à
jéricho et à gaza il faut dire que ces
progrès politique se voit sur le terrain
olivier lerner et alan grego ont ainsi
constaté l'ouverture à ramallah d'une
banque contrôlée par les jordaniens mais
destinées aux palestiniens c'est la
mosquée située juste en face de cette
banque pas tout à fait comme les autres
qui indiquent un peu de choses près les
heures d'ouverture et de fermeture une
banque jordanienne a de nouveau pignon
sur rue en cisjordanie celle-ci à
ramallah et bien la première à rouvrir
ses portes depuis 1967
elle est aussi belle qu'une banque
suisse mais pas encore aussi riche cela
viendra peut-être les clients tous des
palestiniens se pressent au comptoir
depuis plus d'un mois pour déposer
chèque et argent liquide
on ouvre ici en moyenne 120 comptes par
jour depuis le 1er avril 8 monnaies
différentes circule le dollar américain
le dinars jordaniens et le shekel
israélien en priorité j'essaie tomber
mon ancienne banque
j'ai déposé ici douze mille shekels ici
on fait pas la queue pendant des heures
c'est une vraie banque très très
efficace
vingt-quatre mille francs par 6 50 mille
francs par là à ce rythme la banque
jordanienne de ramallah sera riche de
200 millions de francs dans un an
dans ces conditions tout a été prévu
pour se prémunir contre le mob eset où
vous êtes armé vous avez des pistolets
en oeuvre sous le bureau
non nous ne sommes pas armés mon confort
nos parents il n'y a pas eu encore de
hold up
non et on espère battre même si les
territoires sont bouclées depuis
quelques semaines le business va bon
train en cisjordanie la banque
jordanienne a ouvert ses portes au bon
moment mais aujourd'hui les palestiniens
réclament davantage
ils veulent mettre sur le marché leurs
propres monnaies et construire leur
propre banque
en attendant ce sont les jordaniens qui
touche le jackpot
le combat n'a pas eu lieu faute de
combattants les marins pêcheurs français
résolu à laver l'affront infligé dans le
golfe de gascogne par les espagnols
n'ont finalement pas pris la mer ce
matin la gendarmerie maritime les en a
empêchés furieux les marins ont réagi en
bloquant l'accès au port de bayonne
reportage de léo lamberton et bruno
girodon bloqué depuis ce matin 8h30 une
douzaine de chalutiers barre l'entrée du
port de bayonne en phase 5a août un
pétrolier delta qui ten sont obligés de
mouiller au large comme ils ne peuvent
pas rentrer au port
ils attendent la guerre de l'anchois
dire aujourd'hui à une guerre de
positions pourtant 1 4h ce matin les
marins comptait bien aller pêcher
l'anchois près même à se frotter à
nouveau avec les espagnols et quand ils
arrivent à leur chalutier
il découvre que les gendarmes ont scellé
leurs filets sont venus à la main car
les personnes sur les bateaux là comme
de vulgaires voleurs ils nous envient
des scellés et ils ont laissé des prix
du lait des traits d'un bateau qui à
l'espagne l'a 20 est à nous ils nous
connaissaient les voilà l'état français
total michael est écoeuré de voir ça
furieux de ne pouvoir aller en mer il
décide de bloquer le port de bayonne
tant qu'ils n'auront pas obtenu ce qu'il
veut de continuer à pêcher en juin c'est
notre vie c'est notre gagne pain
c'est tout
faux pas on peut pas aller plus loin les
marins reste sourd aux injonctions de
paris le gouvernement leur rappelle
qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de pêcher dans
choix en ce moment d'autant qu'il
négocie avec les espagnols pour qu'il
donne aux français le droit de pêcher
6000 tonnes d'anchois supplémentaires à
partir de juin on n'en veut pas de suite
pourquoi parce que le prochain se trouve
en demander en bretagne alors que du 21
mars au mois de juin le prochain retour
à trois heures de route de chez nous
depuis ses heures une réunion a lieu
entre le préfet des pyrénées atlantiques
et les marins ces derniers ont prévenu
ils n'enlèveront leur bateau que si on
les autorise à pêcher dès demain du
renfort est arrivé dans la journée et
huit autres chalutiers sont attendus
d'ici 24 heures pour renforcer le blocus
ce reportage de léo lamberto nous a été
envoyé juste avant ce journal la réunion
continue mais il est possible que ce
soir ou demain les marins mettre fin au
blocus et il est possible qu'il soit
indemnisé les jours nous ne sortirons
pas manifestation cet après midi à paris
devant le ministère des affaires
sociales de plusieurs centaines
d'éducateurs et d'assistants sociaux
plus précisément des salariés des
centres d'hébergement et de réinsertion
en france il estime ne pas avoir assez
d'argent pour accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions
les sans abris et les exclus un exemple
choisi dans la région messine par maryse
burgot et à la rade chaud j'avais un ami
avant et puis bon ça fait un mal ça a
mal fini
bon ben je cherchais surnom aussi pour
pouvoir me loger elles sont source
n'était pas possible je n'avais pas
treuil
donc je jure m'a proposé le foyer
carrefour et puis je suis venu 19 ans
des parents absents plus de repères en
france elles sont de plus en plus
nombreuses et de plus en plus jeunes à
n'avoir d'autre choix que les centres
d'hébergement d'hébergement et de
réinsertion sociale puisque c'est ainsi
qu'on nomme ces endroits réinsérer c'est
à dire d'abord écouter et parler
gaël n'est pas ici dans un centre
d'accueil d'urgence pour sans abri mais
au sein d'une équipe d'éducateurs de
psychologues savez ici on ne se contente
pas de donner le gîte et le couvert
forcément accueillir des personnes en
difficulté ça un coup au delà du coût
d'hébergement au delà du coût
de la piaule il s'agit d'avoir du
personnel pour le faire autrement on ne
fait que déplacer le problème
les jeunes en difficulté viendront l'a
momentanément et de toute façon s'il n'y
a pas d'espoir seront encore demain plus
amer même si des fois c'est pas toujours
démontré des mickeys l'on peut avoir
avec certains et certaines personnes qui
sont bons et nous pousse je sens bien
qu'ils ne font pas ça pour persécuter
pour mais ça on le sent poussé un coup
de pouce qui nécessite du personnel et
de l'argent
or cette année l'enveloppé budgétaire
accordée aux 700 centres est en baisse
l'état estime entre autres que tout
réinsertion suppose une participation
financière des occupants nous avons
estimé qu' il fallait pour le principe
demander une toute petite prise en
charge pour ceux d héberger qui y avait
qui a fait une rémunération qui avait en
tout cas des des revenus même si ce sont
des revenus qui viennent de prestations
sociales diverses
un choix politique que les responsables
des centres d'hébergement ne partage pas
toujours une précision destinés à la
communauté harkie de france qui va
bénéficier de la part du gouvernement
d'une aide de deux milliards et demi de
francs
la location déterminé par roger romani
le ministre des rapatriés des relations
avec le sénat est bien de 110 mille
francs elle sera versée en une seule
fois ne sera pas imposable
elle s'ajoutera au prime d'accession à
la propriété aux primes d'invalidité et
à toutes les mesures qui seront prises
en faveur de l'emploi et de la formation
des jeunes a requis et l'on reparlera
demain de la sphère om valenciennes le
conseil fédéral organe suprême de la
fédération française de football se
réunira à paris pour prendre une
décision
s'agira-t-il d'une sanction et dans ce
cas quelle serait-elle écoutons rien la
voix
christophe robert sera le premier des
protagonistes de la sphère à être
entendu demain matin au siège de la
fédération
un an bientôt qu'il n'a plus joué au
foot demain il sera définitivement fixé
sur sa carrière sportive m'attends au
pire comme ça s'il y a par miracle une
chance sur cent qu'on ait le droit de
rejouer b/j accueillerait avec plaisir
bochaca eydelie eux ne viendront pas
demain ils seront représentés par leurs
avocats
mais comme robert il espère être
autorisé à rejouer au moins à l'étranger
pour ces trois là les instances
internationales du football poussent en
faveur d'une mesure de clémence
le conseil fédéral entendra plus tard
dans la journée les dirigeants le plus
attendu d'entre eux c'est bernès mais
lui non plus ne viendra pas
commanditaire présumé de la corruption
jean pierre bernès pourrait être le
grand perdant du jour et se voir radier
à vie
dans le cas où ils seraient épargnés
jean pierre bernès envisage de reprendre
du service dans un autre club français
il dit avoir plusieurs propositions
comme jean pierre bernès bernard tapie
en cour une radiation à vie mais lui
quittera bientôt le foot et viendra donc
uniquement plaider la cause de son club
l'avenir de l'om voilà bien l'essentiel
un club qui vient déjà de vivre une
saison sanctions il a été privé du titre
93 de coupe d'europe de super coup deux
coupes intercontinentales
le conseil fédéral pourrait donc estimer
que l'om a suffisamment payé
dans le cas contraire les sanctions
peuvent aller du blâme à la
rétrogradation en division 2 si la
sanction était trop lourde
bernard tapie saisirait alors le conseil
d'état mais la fédération at-elle
intérêt enfoncé l'om au moment où
bernard tapie est à la recherche d'un
repreneur
un repreneur qui devra d'ailleurs
injecter au moins 150 millions de francs
pour équilibrer les comptes de l'om sans
quoi c'est cette fois la ligue dans un
mois qui pourrait empêcher le club
marseillais d'entamer la prochaine
saison en division 1
automobilistes si vous voulez garder vos
choux et vos points rouler bouclé à
partir du 9 mai les sanctions seront
plus sévères si vous oubliez la ceinture
alban nicosie andrzej chyra le port de
la ceinture sera obligatoire sous peine
de perdre des points
est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est une bonne chose
c'est une atteinte à la liberté publique
doit primer
c'est donc du 50 50 on estime à un sur
deux le nombre de conducteurs qui
attachent régulièrement la ceinture de
sécurité un sur deux c'est bien pour
ceux qui l'ont la sécurité routière
souhaite maintenant convaincre les
autres le défaut de port de ceinture
multiplé par presque trois le risque
d'être tué ou blessé gravement dans un
accident qui compris et surtout en ville
le défaut de port de casque multiplie
par deux le risque d'être tué alors
l'idée a jailli
c'est souvent la même renforcé la peur
du gendarme le code de la route qui est
déjà un gros bouquin s'enrichit de deux
nouveaux chapitres le non port du casque
à moto coûtera désormais un point sur
les 12 de votre permis même sanction
pour le défaut de ceinture de sécurité
et pour ceux qui n'ont toujours pas
compris bientôt sur vos écrans
ce petit film ravageur même à 50 à
l'heure
si vous roulez sans savoir attachez
votre ceinture
le choc la force qui vous projette en
avant et de plus de deux tonnes
personne ne peut y résister les hommes
montent au nord et les femmes
aujourd'hui françois mitterrand a reçu à
l'elysée l'ancien ministre socialiste
des droits de la femme yvette roudy qui
a dit il y a trop peu de femmes dans les
assemblées élues
jacques chirac a écrit aujourd'hui dans
le monde le rôle des femmes est encore
et toujours à conquérir
edouard balladur a invité à déjeuner 26
femmes venues de tous les horizons
politiques culturels et sociaux
simone veil nicole notât michel
barjacois hélène luc ont ainsi partagé
le même repas pourquoi cet honneur parce
qu'il y à 50 ans à peine les femmes
obtenaient enfin en france le droit de
voter par la volonté du général de
gaulle aujourd'hui elles s'en servent et
largement mai pour élire qui des hommes
surtout guilaine chenu
ce geste est devenu féminin le 29 avril
je suis très fier de voter et j'espère
que toutes les femmes auront rempli leur
devoir
ce jour-là 12 millions d'électrices vote
pour la première fois avant ce geste il
y aura eu un siècle de débats et de
lutte il y aura eu des hésitations et
des craintes ainsi que des martyrs et
des héroïnes la cause féministe se
défend dans les salons et le plus
souvent dans la rue
de nous faire régulièrement avec
obstination le parlement et le sénat
rejette les projets de loi qui accorde
des droits civiques aux femmes en 44 la
france est encore en guerre
le 21 avril le comité de la libération
nationale publie une ordonnance qui
donne le droit de vote aux femmes
la nouvelle vient d'elle j'ai ce jour là
lucie aubrac et dans la résistance à
londres elle a alors 31 ans
pour moi c'était une chose tellement
normal c'était dans le ton de la
résistance la résistance était un
engagement contre certes les forces
d'occupation mais aussi pour rétablir
les libertés les libertés civiques et
cet engagement il était aussi bien
masculin féminin les femmes ont obtenu 2
droit celui de voter et d'être élu un
demi siècle plus tard elles ne sont que
6% à l'assemblée certes quelques unes
sont au gouvernement parfois même aux
plus hautes charges mais en europe les
femmes françaises sont parmi les moins
représentées il ya aujourd'hui moins de
femmes élues au parlement qu'il y en
avait en 1946 donc allé droit conquérir
c'est la parité c'est à dire l'égalité
parfaite dans la représentation
deux textes ont été déposés au parlement
pour inscrire la parité dans la loi pour
certaines femmes c'est la seule solution
pour d'autres comme elisabeth hubert il
faut compter avec le temps ce n'est plus
un handicap d'être une femme pour être
candidate à des élections mais il faut
convaincre les femmes de s'engager en
politique y compris dans un système dans
lequel ne se sentent pas obligatoirement
à l'aise que je pars foch comprend entre
les premières candidates d'hier et celle
d'aujourd'hui 50 ans se sont écoulés
l'égalité politique est encore loin et
pourtant aux prochaines élections
européennes plusieurs parties présentent
des listes à parité hommes femmes une
exception qui pourrait devenir à terme
un usage autre temps autres moeurs si le
problème de l'inégalité des sexes posait
à nouveau parce qu'il est résolu n'est
ce pas comment réagir et aura qui ferait
ton appel pour défendre les droits de la
femme à une agence de pub par exemple et
comment réagira-t-elle agnès molinier
marcel martin ont sollicité l'agencé
australie
et oui mesdames c'est au bistrot souvent
que les hommes parlent de vue alors
c'est ce lieu qu'ont choisi les
publicitaires de lagence australie pour
faire passer leurs messages pour
l'anniversaire de votre droit de vote
on va filmer ici même à leurs deux
personnes deux hommes qui regardent des
femmes passées qui des juges comme des
femmes avec des culs dessins et des
machins et comme des femmes objets il
est temps de regarder des hommes n'aura
pas changé il ya autunois qui pourra
faire que les femmes auront droit de
cité
reste à trouver le bon ton avec cette
folie et de provocation la halle au gras
ça reste quand même une petite image de
clipser c'est un condensé de la vie donc
je dis pas que tout le monde fait ça
mais disons qu'au cas où on sait jamais
résultat cette pub cela mais qu est ce
qu a dit hier mais c'est bien q
corriveau deux jambes
grâce à ces jeux la frange de la burj
latour jabbour les toffes les petites
étoiles et morgane ou c'est moi regarde
c'est faire bouger un petit peu les gens
c'est à dire qu'on veut pas leur dire
c'est un scandale et qui vous disent
d'accord avec vous
on veut qu'ils se disent il ya encore
des choses à faire donc c'est une
question de prise de conscience on va
les faire bouger dans leur attitude dans
leur comportement et que après ça quand
et une femme se disent tiens ça me
rappelle quelque chose
et comme c'est un homme quand il agit
comme ça parce qu'on continuera déjà
comme ça on n'en pas une conscience
elles sont là peut-être changer faire
bouger les mentalités c'était le but de
ce spot aux termes parfois un peu cru
car finalement 50 ans après le droit de
vote des femmes elles ne peuvent
toujours pas avoir leur vraie place dans
la société
du moins sans se battre si vous aimez le
cinéma et si vous y allez souvent voilà
ce que vous verrez à partir du 26 avril
et pendant six semaines avant le film
détendez vous laissez vous porter c'est
très différent de ce que vous venez de
voir précédemment
je veux rêver
ouais
je veux rêver à tire d'aile d'une france
pépère
imaginez tous les possibles avons fait
l'impossible
offrir la nature
nos ambitions
je
je rêvais
dessiner une vision humaine de six des
huit ans elle
je ferai
je veux résident attire t elle
je veux rêver attire tellement in france
ouais
et savez-vous par qui ce clip a été
commandée par charles pasqua
non pas le ministre de l'intérieur mais
le ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire c'est son autre casquette
charles pasqua invite ainsi les jeunes à
participer au grand débat sur
l'aménagement du territoire a décidé en
quelque sorte la france de demain et
elle a dessiné en planant envoyé spécial
le gouffre en revanche naviguer ce soir
à 20h50 paul nahon et bernard benyamin
nous raconterons dans le magazine de la
rédaction l'histoire du france du france
devenu norway qui donne du bon temps à
des centaines de touristes dans les
caraïbes une véritable usine à touristes
auparavant sophie davant vous annoncera
le retour du printemps demain promis
juré et valérie maurice parlera de la
circulation
philippe lefait vous présentera le
dernier journal à 00h15 avant une
émission spéciale que michel fils
consacrera à jean carmet mais avant de
conclure je voudrais vous donner une
information qu edouard balladur a donné
chez nos confrères de tf1
une grande consultation sera lancée sur
la jeunesse ecoutons-le extrait du
premier ministre il y aura des
universitaires il y aura des
syndicalistes y aura des chefs
d'entreprises y aura des professeurs y
aura des jeunes dépouillera le
questionnaire lui même j'espère que très
nombreux seront les jeunes qui
répondront il s'agit d'instituer un
dialogue entre la société les jeunes
pour qu' il n'y a pas d' incompréhension
entre eux car c'est ça ce que cette
affaire du ces ip a montré et ce comité
dépouillera donc le questionnaire et
fera des propositions librement au
gouvernement le gouvernement
n'interviendra pas dans cette affaire
c'est ce comité qui gérera cette
opération c'est ce montage était un peu
comment dit-on quote part dont jacques
toubon un peu serré voilà ce journal les
terminé bonne soirée sur france 2 à
demain 20 heures daniel bilalian vous
présentera le journal à 13h bonsoir